لا توم موسكو لواشنطن و برلين ومن معهما
لا مفاوضات بشرط سحب القوات الروسيه من
اوكرانيا ولا تراجع عن التكتيك العسكريه
الحالي في الحرب ساعه من الاخذ والرد عبر
الهاتف بين الرئيس بوتين والمستشار
الالماني الشوز انتهت كمادات على خلاف
بشان جوهر القضايا المطروحات جاء في بيان
الكريم
الاوكرانيه من التدابير التي لا مفر منها
لمواجهه الهجمات الاستفزازيه لكيف بيان
برلين تحدث عن حث المستشار الرئيس الروسي
على التوصل باسرع وقت ممكن الى حل
دبلوماسي يتضمن انسحاب القوات الروسيه كما
ابلغه المانيا القصر الروسي للمنشات
المدنيه الاوكرانيه سبق المكالمه لم تغير
شيئا في خريطه المواقف رد على العرض
المقدم من الرئيس الامريكي صرح المتحدث
باسم الكرملان ان بيضا قال عمليا ان
المفاوضات لن تكون ممكنه الا بعد ان يخرج
بوتن من اوكرانيا وهو مطرده مسك بوضوح على
حد تعبيره واكد استمرار العمليه العسكريه
كان الرئيس الامريكي وبحضور نظيره الفرنسي
عبر عن استعداده التحدث مع بوتن اذا سحب
قوته من اوكرانيا واظهر نيه الحرب في ظل
كل هذه التطورات هل اصبحت امكانيه الحل
التكلوماسي بعيده اكثر فاكثر لا تغلق
موسكو الباب نهائيا ولكنها لا تقبل
المطالبه الغربيه لفتح قنوات اتصال جديه
تضع حدا للحرب المدمره للجميع ولا قررت في
ختام اجتماع منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا الذي في بولندا عدم السماح لوزير
الخارجيه روسيا بالحضور اشعل حرب تصريحات
اتهم لافروف الولايات المتحده وحلف الاطلس
بمحاولتي تقويض عمل اي هيئه اقليميه فاتف
الى تعزيز الحوار مثل منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا رابطه دول جنوب شرق
اسيا وقال ان الحديث عن اهتمام الغرب
بالتوصل الى نوع من التسويه السلميه لا
يسيروا اهتمام روسيا التصعيد المزدوج
دبلوماسيه وعسكريا في الحرب الى متى من
سيناريو سيئين الى اسوا تمضي شهور صراع
تداعياته المؤلمه ابعده من اوكرانيا بكثير